I look up there that's a big bird
yeah well you think that is I don't know
maybe it's a maybe it's a crow babies ah
seven hours
wait a minute smell that this muscle
except
we'll say basketball you stand before
Wardell Stefan curry of house golden
state second of his name Fresh Prince
baby-faced assassin sinker of threes and
brother of splashes don't be afraid my
friend the King says you may approach
and speak as zona de defensa
they want the the citta pika their sword
an he is a Denver nugget he says he
prayed for your victory against the
pelicans I thank him for his prayers in
stone office back to rare possesses war
layup it was your crossover he says it
broke his ankles
there's another tub this one suits me
fine
don't worry not interested I just want
this season to be over you swore a
solemn vow remember you're supposed to
help me win a championship I didn't
intend to get hurt
chemistry matters Kevin stop trying to
find a way to fit out and just to fit in
be a part of something special just my
thoughts make all your big men
you lost friend forgive me for staring I
don't see many Clippers where I am from
you know I don't see many rocket men in
the City of Angels we don't like the
smog come with me my beard now why are
you wasting a center like this on a bush
face choker do you know why the whole
world hates a clipper you think you're
complaining and you're acting tough
makes you worth two billion gold but
you're just a whiny little baby who's
far too slow on the flop
[Music]